Inside this low-key Santa Monica office building,...
...Microsoft's plotting its TV future and it's tied to this.
Xbox Entertainment Studios is a unit of Xbox created to make original TV shows.
This is the startup with the help of Microsoft.
Led by longtime Hollywood executive Nancy Tellem,...
...Xbox Studios is developing all sorts of shows.
A Steven Spielberg-produced Halo series,...
...a robot thriller called "Humans,"...
...planned live coverage of the Bonnaroo Music Festival,...
...a reality show on street soccer ahead of the World Cup.
To watch, you'll fire up your Xbox...
...and if you're one of the 48 million members of its online entertainment network Xbox Live,...
...you may be able to stream Xbox Originals...
...the same way you'd watch Netflix or play interactive video games.
Microsoft may also strike partnership deals...
...to distribute some of the shows outside of Xbox.
And shows will also be interactive.
If you're up for it, you'll be able to do funky stuff gamers like to do,...
...that's different than lying on your couch watching cable.
Microsoft's doing this to keep Xbox loyalists happy but also to broaden its reach.
It's estimated each Xbox sold is worth a thousand bucks in purchases to Microsoft...
...between games, shows and Xbox Live, a number that would climb if TV is a success.
Original shows also fit with Microsoft's goal of making Xbox One...
...the anchor of its home entertainment network,...
...connecting to other Microsoft devices like tablets and phones.